on est aux petites heures qui précèdent
l'aube le docteur peschier tombe dans
les bras de sa famille il reste libre
le juge des libertés et de la détention
n'a pas suivi les réquisitions du
procureur jouant peut-être la carte de
la modération face à l'emballement
médiatique au g10 ciel vous savez dans
ce dossier d'aucuns ont parlé de gilles
de rais du docteur petiot peut-être que
le juge des libertés et de la détention
a pensé à marie besnard qui elle aussi a
été accusé de 12 empoisonnement avant
d'être acquitté en tout cas c'est une
décision qui est une décision courageuse
mais pleinement respectueuse des
principes du droit sur laquelle la
détention provisoire est l'exception
et il nous semblait fondamental que le
docteur péché puisse rester libre pour
sa famille c'est tout ce qui lui reste
on lui a pris son travail sa vie
professionnelle il ne lui reste plus que
cette liberté et c'était essentiel de la
conserver l'audience du jld s'est
finalement déroulée à huit clos
provoquant la colère des avocats un trio
de haute volée pressé d'en découdre
quelques heures auparavant en effet le
procureur de la république avait ouvert
le feu convoquant une conférence de
presse avant même la mise en examen
officiel du médecin anesthésiste listant
les éléments à charge
d'abord l'arrêt des événements
indésirables graves il expliqué depuis
qu'il n'exerce plus à la clinique saint
vincent en mars 2010 est la
multiplication des événements
indésirables graves dont les périodes de
conflits intense entre lui et ses
collègues au sein de la clinique saint
vincent
par ailleurs un certain nombre de 40
était en capacité de faire des
diagnostics précoces dans des situations
punique où rien ne permettait à ce stade
deux suspects et à surdosage en
potassium aux anesthésiques locaux une
manoeuvre d'intimidation de plus pour
les avocats qui dénoncent un faisceau
d'indicés concordants
mais pas graves et concordants ce qui
est indispensable pour être mise en
examen
il ne faut pas oublier que nous sommes
la défense et qu'il n'est que
l'accusation que si nous sommes
subjectif dans notre défense
il est subjective dans son accusation et
que l'interprétation et je ne pense pas
que jean yves le borgne ici présent me
contredise que l'interprétation que fait
le parquet de besançon et les enquêteurs
de certains éléments factuels qui à mon
sens
sont interprétés à charge contre le
docteur p astier soit la réalité du dos
si le vrai problème précisément c'est
qu'il y à un certain nombre de gens je
n'en dirai pas plus qu'ils ont pu le cas
échéant se rendre coupable d'une
manipulation soit erroné soit criminel
et qu' il n'y a aucune raison de penser
que c'est le docteur peschier et lui
seul qui en a été l'auteur 19 heures
après la fin de sa garde à vue le
docteur pesci repart libre avec le
soutien indéfectible de sa famille
le médecin a néanmoins l'interdiction de
rester chez lui à besançon son exil sous
contrôle judiciaire se fera dans l'ouest
de la france